et bien on est presque surpris de voir
une équipe de France qui massacre les
All Blacks ou presque victoire du 15 de
France 27 à 13 en ouverture de cette
coupe du monde de rugby messieurs on
pouvait pas mieux commencer on est
content non ah ben on est très content
certains sur ce plateau avait
pronostiqué la victoire de la France pas
d'autres on pas le rappeler mais non non
c'est bien parce que la deuxème mi-temps
a
été dominé par les Français il y a eu la
répétition de la première mi-temps
c'està-dire un essai black à la 2è
minute mais on a beaucoup mieux maîtrisé
cette deuxième mi-temps on s'est imposé
et le dernier essai il est symptomatique
c'est-à-dire que les Blacks regardent le
ballon rebondir là où les Français eux
entre penau et Jaminet veulent s'en
saisir s'ans saisi c'est marque Carl mus
rédacteur en chef au Figaro Magazine
Vincent bornenav journaliste sciences
mais passionné spécialiste de rugby et
puis Augustin morio bonsoir merci de
nous rejoindre journaliste Figaro Live
vous avez vu comment m'a répondu Carl il
y a 10 ans en arrière l'équipe de France
bat par exemple cette équipe de All
Blacks vous croyez vraiment qu'il aurait
parlé comme ça non c'est c'est assez
incroyable ce à quoi on vient d'assister
objectivement ce qui m'épate moi c'est
vraiment le le calme justement avec
lequel céit fait l'aptie quand même des
Black en 2ème mi-temps je pense qu'il
faut le il faut le signaler
mais c'est vrai que pendant la deuxième
mi-temps à partir du moment où on prend
le score on ne voyait pas comment est-ce
que les Blacks pouvaient nous mettre en
danger on avait pas l'impression de
jouer les All Black qu'on a pu jouer ces
dernières années et je pense qu'il faut
quand même le mettre au crédit du du 15
de France qui a su les les canacés les
dominer et marquer sur ses points forts
non non c'est c'est c'est une deuxème
mi-temps assez exceptionnelle et et un
grand match ouverture auquel on assisté
euh je rectifie on a une indécision ça
me fait penser au match de l'équipe de
France l'année dernière de football le
score 29 à 13 donc la transformation est
passée ok la transformation de de Jamin
a été validée on va changer tout ça sur
les sur les saintés sur le titre bon
grande nouvelle Augustin ça vous
surprend cette victoire ou qu'à moitié
finalement bah déjà pour revenir sur ce
que disait Carl c'est même pas la
deuxème mi-temps c'est à partir de la
60e et c'est ce qui fait la force du
rugby c'est que en un/ers de match on
arrive à renverser complètement la
vapeur et la belle histoire c'est penau
qui fait quand même deux erreurs assez
marquantes défensives qui se ratape
quasiment trois fois quasiment quatre
d'ailleurs parce que le l'élier Johan a
réussi à sauver au dernier moment cet
essai mais il aura pour mettre quasiment
trois ou quatre donc Speno se rattrape
de ses fautes et puis jaminais jaminais
qu'on a beaucoup critiqué mais qui a
réussi à être vigoureux et à prendre
d'ailleurs un poste à l'arrière en fin
de match bon deux deux mi-temps très
différentes première mi-tempsquelle la
France a viré en tête en étant dominé et
deuxième mi-temps alors là il y avait
pas photo très clairement Carl une
équipe très très clairement supérieure
en fait c'est c'est ce que disait y tout
à l'heure c'est-à-dire que la première
mi-emps on sentait les deux équipes
stressé oui
l'en peut-être la chaleur le fait de les
blagues qui voulaient prendre une
revanche se livra pas trop les Bleus qui
voulaient pas perdre ce match bon la
deuxème mi-temps elle a été beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus
ouverte mais quasiment plus décousu
d'ailleurs plus décousu d'ailleurs il y
a eu des moments un petit peu oui très
décousus mais on les a dominé ou puis on
a vu on a vu des Français avec le ballon
ce qu'on a très peu vu en première
mi-tempou et on a senti des blacks qui
était euh je suis d'accord avec toi
incapable de répondre euh c'est pas
faire minimiser l'exploit des Bleus mais
cette équipe black elle est pas au
niveau de des équipes black qu'on a pu
connaître avant il y avait des en avant
qu'on voyait pas 11 pénalités sur tout
le match c'est c'est énorme à ce
niveau-là surtout si en face la France
en a fait que on a commis que que deux
ils ont eu un carton jaune c'est c'est
compliqué de jouer avec carton orange du
jaune en plus oui on a découvert
l'existence de ce cart ou c'esti al on
peut expliquer cette règle d'ailleurs
parce que certains l'ont peut-être
découvert devant la télé il y a la
possibilité pour l'arbitre de parfaire
sa décision après avoir mis un carton
jaune et de pouvoir transformmer ce
carton en carton rouge c'est ça ex ouais
c'est plutôt une bonne chose parce qu'on
avait beaucoup de de séquences vidéo qui
duraient qui était interminable pour
savoir si le joueur était tombé sur la
tête sur l'épaule là un arbitre vidéo va
regarder ça pendant que le jeu continue
et là il se trouve que Thomas Ramos
était tombé sur le côté donc la faute y
était mais il y avait pas le côté très
grave de de faire tomber sur la tête
donc carton jaune nous sommes en direct
sur le garo.fr je salue Claudus bravo
les petits nous avez dit aller les
petits avant le match superbe équipe de
France on est aussi sur Youtube vous
réagissez je vous donne le le programme
peut-être des thèmes qu'on va qu'on va
pouvoir discuter ensemble une victoire
de champion peut-être euh beaucoup plus
de joururs de mi-temps l'a déjà évoqué
grand bleu ou petit black hein ça c'est
une vraie question euh alors laisser des
blacks est-ce qu'il était valide parce
qu'on s'est fait peur alors
que il est valide voilà ce compte c'est
qu'on a gagné et et vraiment battre les
blagus quoi qu'il arrive c'est toujours
un exploit et c'est grand bleu grande
équipe de France je vous poserai la
question pour vous demander réfléchissz
ce que c'est déjà l'équipe de France la
plus forte de l'histoire hein on peut
déjà se projeter pourquoi pas et puis on
ira sur la suite les prochains matchs et
on peut déjà se tourner quasiment vers
vers les quarts de finale maintenant
nous sommes quasiment assurés même s'il
reste trois matchs d'être en tête de
groupe mais est-ce que c'est une bonne
chose parce que si ça se trouve il
faudra mieux prendre l'Afrique du Sud ou
l'Irlande fa l're groupe on verra le
match Irlande Afrique du Sud on va
d'abord au Stade de France Vincent
roseron vous étiez un des chanceux dans
le stade avec un certain Jean-Marc Gonin
votre collègue au Figaro Magazine grand
reporter parlez-nous tous les deux de
l'ambiance vous avez passé un bon
moment ah c'était le Stade de France
dans cet étatl j'avais jamais vu
honnêtement alors j'étais pas là à la
finale de 98 du football mais
franchement un enthousiasme et même
puisque les Blacks nous avaient promis
de marquer tout et de faire taire le
stade et ben même quand les BLS ont
marqué tôt le stade a continué à faire
du bruit c'est-à-dire quand même que les
Bleus ont un public absolument déchaîné
derrière eux et qui ne laissent pas
passer un temps mort effectivement ça a
été impressionnant dès le début
effectivement ce ce euh ce cet essai
marqué tout de suite mais qui n'a pas du
tout calmé euh les supporters français
sur chaque mêlée ça ça a crié et même
quand les Français ont commençait à
prendre parfois un peu l'au en première
mi-temps où c'était un peu compliqué
tout le stade est é derrière eux très
vite alors nous on l' pas vraiment senti
pour tout dire déjà se plaindre
peut-être de cette marseillaise au début
de match où on n' pas vibré comme vous
vous avez peut-être vibr tiens Vincent
la marseillaise au début elle était si
extraordinaire que ça parce que nous on
n pas bien entendu on n' pas entendu un
stade chanter à plein poumon
quoi ben moi j'ai eu l'impression qu'il
y avait un problème de tempo un peu
problme tempo puis bon c'est voix
d'enfant c'est très joli mais quand vous
avez 80000 personnes qui chantent autour
ça donne quand même une impression de
cacophonie
assez assez saisissante c'était pas très
réussi pour tout dire et les flonflons
d'une fanfare ça accompagne mieux les
les cœurs du public que des jeunes gens
aussi talentueux furtiles ouais bon on
va en studio même constat en studio oui
voilà bon on est on est d'accord sur sur
cette question tiens on a commencé à
évoquer ce match dei-temps est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec nous une
première mi-temps où les Bleus ont
souffert environ en tête et puis une
deuxième mi-temps alors là il presque
plus de match non
oui oui les les Bleus les Bleus ont su
faire dans la première mi-temps avec des
avec des phases de jeu où ils étaient
pas là quoi quand même on se fait passer
sur des petits coup de pied par-dessus
qui sont même un grand classique du
rugby on peut pas dire que soit une
grande inversion des blacks mais le
deuxième rideau n'était pas là on avait
une troisème ligne qui a été qui a eu
qui était très longue à se mettre en
marche et donc on avait un deuxième
rideau de défense très très absent j'ai
trouvé moi et c'était inquiétant même
parce que quand même on a la troisème
ligne c'est notre arme fatale avec notre
notre demine mêlé il faut le dire et là
on était un peu on était assez loin du
compte on est on a fini la mi-temps sur
notre fin moi je pense qu'il faut que
vous la deème mi-temps on a on a basculé
dans une domination mais vu enfin quand
on est au stage je peux vous dire qu'il
y avait le facteur dominant de ce match
il y avait les deux équipes et les temps
mort leur temps mort et leur temps
faible mais il y avait un temps fort
permanent c'était la chaleur et et
franchement faire sortir 30 rug sur la
pelouse par cette température là c'est
inhumain je sais pas si vous avez vu la
tête par exemple d'aldrit qui était
absolument rouge il a jeté son casque il
en pouvait plus euh il y avait des
joueurs qui avaient un mal fou à se
replacer euh les les Français étaient
assez vite fatigués et alors en deuxième
mi-temps les blackes on peut dire qu'on
les a dominé mais ils ont été totalement
oxy par la chaleur vous avez vu la
foulée de Boden Barret qui a été diminué
par deux euh leur crochet était nul et
en plus ils ont dû jouer à 14 parce que
Jordan a fait une grosse faute donc
c'était vraiment les Blacks finissent le
match mais totalement ils n'ont plus
rien dans les chaussettes j'ai rarement
vu ça inéress complètement plongé
physiquement plongé physiquement ouais
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
est-ce que les Bleus d'ailleurs pourront
faire la différence dans cette Coupe du
Monde physiquement est-ce qu'ils sont
plus forts physiquement que les autres
ça s'est vérifié ça dans les derniers
mois les dernières années ou non pas
tellement céit surtout techniquement
qu'ils étaient plus forts ils sont plus
forts techniquement mais la force de
Fabien galti on disait aussi tout à
l'heure c'est qu' euh il a réussi à
faire en sorte que quand les remplaçants
arrivent les finisseurs non seulement le
le niveau ne baisse pas mais peut-être
même il monte un peu il augmente en poid
en plus dans les ml voilà tu disais tout
à l'heure au niveau de la partir de la
60e c'est là effectivement qu'il y a eu
un certain nombre de finisseurs qui sont
rentrés euh ta au fienua la fraîcheur en
plus et c'est là qu'on a débloqué un peu
notre
compteur qu'on a mis les BLS à mal et
malgré eux euh leur banc aussi qui
rentrent mais qui fait pas la différence
le débat continue sur Youtube entre le
score 2713 ou 2913 alors certains sites
internetmission oui on et puis à la
limite qu'est- est-ce que ça change
alors si ça peut changer parce qu'en cas
d'égalité à la fin attz je sors la
calculette oui si rugby c'est deux
équipes sont en égalité ce qui est rare
mais ça peut arriver deux équipes sont
en égalité de points la différence va se
faire aussi au nombre de de points qui
ont été marqués donc il faut marquer le
plus de points possible les points de
bonus h bon ou on y on y je reviens vers
vous au Stade de France Vincent
Jean-Marc on se demandait est-ce que
c'est 2713 selon war rugby 2713 2713 on
se met d'accord sur ce score tiens
d'ailleurs vous avez un une indication
au stade quel a été le score annoncé à
la fin par le
speaker on est on est on est sorti avant
la fin alors moi je moi moi vous savez
Thib je prépare le matériel pour être
prêt dès la fin du match et Jean-Marc
Gonin était un tellement bon élève j'ai
vu Jamin marquer et je me suis levé de
bonne heure mais aussi parce que je
devais rejoindre Vincent donc je pe j'ai
demandé la première question que j'ai
posé à Vincent je dis tu as le score
parce que je suis parti trop
vite vous avez l'impression que ça a été
une formalité je disais il a 10 ans en
arrière une victoire comme celle-ci on
l'aurait fêté côtillon marseillaise en
plateau bon là le job est fait est-ce
que vous avez aussi ce sentiment là
oui oui oui c'était il fallait se peler
comme on dit dans le rugby voilà c'est
fait c'est c'est bien fait en plus c'est
il y a pas de discussion personne on
verra la presse anglosaxon demain qui
sont souvent qui ont souvent la dendure
avec les Français mais là on a on a
vraiment réussi le match avec des imperf
c'est le premier match ils vont monter
en puissance au fur et à mesure du
tournoi mais il est clair que le le
boulot est fait est bien fait
effectivement le débat qui s'ouvre sur
les potentiels adversaires maintenant en
quart de finale Benjamin qui nous dit
attention à l'Afrique du Sud et puis
Laurence qui nous dit oui oui l'Afrique
du Sud c'est très fort j'en vois
d'autres qui parlent de l'Irlande on se
projette déjà un peu plus loin on va se
concentrer encore un peu sur sur ce
match bon vraie question est-ce qu'on a
vu une grande équipe de France qui peut
aller au bout ou une équipe équipe de
Nouvelle-Zélande faible qui elle n'ira
pas loin je répondais tout à l'heure un
peu mais battre les Black c'est un
exploit c'est vraiment alors il y a la
question de la chaleur après ce qu'on a
vu ils vous ont épaté ces blacks is ils
ont perdu face à l'Afrique du Sud après
avoir juste après être arrivé en Europe
avec le décalage horaire et cetera alors
que les sudaf étaient là depuis plus
longtemps mais il restaient sur victoire
ils ont marché sur rugby Championship ce
championnat de de l'hémisphère sud ça
reste quand même une grande équipe ça
reste la référence il y a pas beaucoup
d'équipes de rugby qui qui Batt les
Blacks donc ça il faut quand même le
dire il faut pas minimiser cet exploit
d'ord c'est la première défaite des
blacks en Pol de l'histoire oui aussi
donc donc pour s pour battre les Blacks
il faut une grande équipe ça c'est sûr
les Blacks étaient peut-être moins fort
que d'habitude moins fort que il y a 4
ans moins fort qu' 8 ans et peut-être
moins fort que pendant la suite de cette
compétition mais faut fa une grande
équipe pour sortir le Augustin c'est
précisément une grande équipe parce
qu'elle a pas super bien joué et qu'elle
a gagné et les demi-temps elle a gagné
les demi-temps même quand elle a été
dominé en plus ouais et tout à l'heure
vous parliez de de la force physique des
Français il reste quand même un obstacle
physique c'est les Sud-Africains c'est
la meilleure équipe pH oua on aa la
discussion sur le quart de finale mais
les sudfri les Irlandais aussi c'est les
les trois plus grandes équipes
aujourd'hui de très loin vous pensez
Carl je les ai je les écoute ils me
disent que finalement ces blacks il
valent pas ils arrivent pas la chfie des
Irlandais des Sud-Africains vous êtes
d'accord ou pas parce que si finalement
vous me dites que c'était une grande
nation bon bah les Irlandais et les
Sud-Africains on va les croquer comme on
a croqué les Blacks quoi là là attention
les Irlandais et les Sud-Africains ont
battu les Blacks donc ils sont un cran
au-dessus mais on on réussit un grand
exploit et surtout on marque d'entré
exactement la Coupe du Monde de rudby et
les on envoie un signal la France ce
soir a envoyé un signal à la planète
rugby on est là vous nous disiez favoris
ou pas machin et ben on assume notre
statut parce que c'est ça qui est
important et je par parle sous votre
contrôle sous le contrôle de de
Jean-Marc on a vu plusieurs Coupes du
monde mais ce qui est impressionnant
c'est que là on a une vraie équipe on a
un impression d'une équipe où chacun est
prêt à à mourir sur le terrain pour
l'autre à aller à vraiment on voit cette
cohésion d'équipe une solidarité à pr
une solidarité c'est le mot que je
cherchais et on voit une concentration
on a l'impression que cette équipe elle
est sûre de sa force à aucun moment on
l'a senti paniquer sur le terrain il y a
eu des moments difficiles dès la les
deux premières minutes oui on se fait
trouer on avait dit 2è minute de la
première mi-temps 3è de la 2è voilà et
là on prend peur on se dit oh là là ça
va être la marée noire on va se prendre
les blqus et tout et ben non cette
équipe elle a su revenir elle est là
tout le temps et c'est c'est la force
que lui a inculqué Fabien Galtier quand
on parlait des défaites encourageantes
et tout là on veut plus de ça non là ils
veulent gagner ils ont leur objectif
c'est le 28 octobre la finale et là ils
ont envoyé un signal à toutes les autres
équipes la France est là il faudra
compter avec elle les images en direct
de la Place de la Concorde ou de N
nombreux Français se sont réunis pour
suivre ce premier match on espère voir
ça dans un mois et demi avec une place
de la Concorde pleine à craquer
Jean-Marc même question pour vous grand
15 de France ou petit All
Blacks moi je suis parfaitement d'accord
avec mon ami Carl on a une équipe qui
est parfaitement préparée mentalement
pas souvenons-nous de du début de la
Coupe du Monde qui avait lu en France
France Argentine et la défaite avec la
de guimoke les types qui avaent Tul qui
qui tremblait et cetera et et on finit
notre premier match battu là à aucun
moment et quand on était dans le stade
moi j'ai d moment j'en ai j'étais à côté
de Vinc on en a parlé je me suis dit ça
ça sent mauvais par le moment mais les
cadres sont là vous voyez un Dupon qui
est solide même même même jellber qui
était qui qui est moins bon défenseur
qu'entamac et cetera vous avez vu le
coup de Rin qui met sur l'essai de penau
ces garsl ils ont ils ont un mental
d'acier quand ils ont aldrd qui était à
un moment crevé fin de première mi-temps
il marchait on s'est dit deè mi-temp il
va pas avancer voyez la deè mi-temps qui
fait il est là tout le temps pour
gratter et ce la trè ligne une deuxè vie
en deè mi-temps exceptionnelle donc ça
c'est des on peut voyager avec des
équipes comme ça indiscutablement là il
y a un socle une solidité mentale et
physique de cette équipe
qui votre
avis
vcent préciser le quel Vincent Vincent r
je vous entends pas assz Vincent vous me
manquez dites-moi ce que vous en pensez
vous je parle trop je parle trop
effectivement non non non non Jean
marque je suis très content d'avoir un
consultant d'ailleurs je vous rappelle
que on a un consultant qui jouer en
première division de française de rugby
jeangonin on ne l'oublie pas mais oui
pour pour pour répondre à la question
que j'ai oublié d'ailleurs est vous
pouvez me la reposer parce que je l'ai
oublié entreemps vous foutz de moi
Vincent est-ce que c'est une équipe de
France incroyable qui a gagné ce match
ou des tout petits BLS qui l'ont
perdu un peu les deux mon général est-ce
que j'ai encore le droit de faire ce
genre de réponse mais non non comme
disait Vincent mon autre collègue
Vincent bordonav je suis d'accord avec
lui il faut pas banaliser le fait de
battre les All Black c'est assez
impressionnant ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui on a réussi à à les battre
même au moment où on on voit où ça va
moins bien et ben là on y arrive et on
on leur enfin même en étant dominé on on
arrive à accepter not en fort et
derrière bah on les mange physiquement
sur la deuxè mi-temps c'est ça qui est
vraiment impressionnant je voulais
ouvrir le débat d'un sur finalement un
fait de match mais c'est intéressant
parce qu'on a souvent parlé de la vidéo
dans plein de sport le deuxème essai de
All Blacks qui peut peut-être faire
basculer la rencontre parce qu'à ce
moment-là on se dit mince on en prend un
deuxième encore une erreur pourquoi il
est validé sans que la vidéo soit
visionnée par les arbitres l'arbitre
pense qu'il est bien placé il juge queès
pr il juge que il juge que la passe est
en arrière à l'écran on a l'impression
qu'il est en avant moi j'ai l'impression
ce qu'il faut juger c'est le mouvement
des bras on n pas eu beaucoup de ralenti
pour pour vérif quel est la règle qui
décide que s'il y a un doute s'il y a un
doute l'arbitre doit se référer au
mouvement des bras si les bras vont vers
l'arrière c'estàd que l'intention de
faire la passe euh et et d'aller vers
l'arrière et donc on siffle pas en avant
après il y a toute la question physique
de l'inertie c'est que quand on court
avec une BAL qu'on la lâche la BAL
avance mais euh doncz-moi ça oui je
cours avec la balle même si je la mets
je donne la balle en arrière si je fa
une passe à plat elle va avancer avec
moi pour faire une passe en arrière il
faut vraiment ce momentl en avant ou non
non non partir moment où la les bras
vont vers l'arrière où il y a vraiment
la volonté de faireord passe arrière la
la règle c'est de c'est de c'est de
consider que la passe est en arrière là
il y a pas il y a pas eu de vidéo
demandé donc on n pas eu 15000 ralentis
sur le sur la les bras la l'essai est
accordé à la fois c'est bien parce que
la vidéo c'est quand même fatiguant ça
ça casse le jeu et c'est que si on perd
le match là-dessus on aurait pu on
aurait pu rouspéter mais bon et puis un
autre fait de jeu c'est Damien penau à
qui on refuse un un essai qui ne touche
pas le ballon on dit en avant mais on a
cette discussion de manière trèsble il
semble qu'il touche pas ball ouais et on
a cette discussion de très mais on
aurait pu en faire tout un scandale
c'est parce qu'il y a ce score si large
car vous ça vous intéresse pas on a
gagné c'est ça le le score final fait
qu'effectivement le débat est moins
important mais c'est vrai que il faut
faire confiance à l'arbitre de champ
l'arbitre fait partie du jeu oui oui oui
on a vu d'ailleurs il était par exemple
sur une trajectoire de balle sur oui oui
oui il faut accepter avant qu'il ait les
vidéos les arbitres se trompait
peut-être plus on parle souvent de
l'essai incroyable de blan en
demi-finale avec les Australiens sur la
première Coupe du monde en 1987 bah avec
les règles d'aujourd'hui avec la vidéo
l'ESS serait pas accordé mais
inversement on aura éé en final en 95
mais bon voilà Jean-Marc Vincent vous
dans le stade on a entendu les siffl à
la télé j'imagine que sur les écrans
géants on peut voir et revoir ses
actions est-ce que à ce moment-là le
stade peut faire basculer une décision
ça a pas été le cas ce soir est-ce que
vous avez senti une ferveur et une par
peut-être une colère ça peut servir un
match une coupe du monde à domicile dans
certains matchs un peu tendus sur des
arbitresbitre qui a extrêmement
chevronné sud-africain protestant assez
inébranlable donc très difficile de le
faire revenir sur une décision et je
voudrais préciser une chose c'est que
les pupitres de presse de notre tribune
de presse où nous trouvions nous
l'équipe du Figaro on était quasiment en
face de la ligne de passe et à aucun
moment nous n'avons vu un en avant
effectivement on a vraiment pas eu nous
cette impression d'En Avant que vous
avez pu avoir et en fait quand le stade
a créé quand d P s'est arrêté de jouer
on pas vraiment
pour nous il y avait pas en avant du
tout et effectivement par contre
l'arbitre vous disiez très
Chevreux il il a hésité mais ENF c'est
quand même un c'est quand même un des
meilleurs arbitres au monde et en plus
il Jacob peer c'est un homme qui a des
idées bien arrêté en général débat fermé
merci voilà il suffisait de demander à
nos reporters sur le terrain non mais ça
peut jouer cette ambiance peut-être dans
cette Coupe du monde à un moment ou un
autre si c'est serré euh on est à
égalité à 5 minutes de la fin j'imagine
que la pression d' un public ça peut
compter non mais d'ailleurs je trouve
c'est surtout Jean-Marc et Vincent qui
pouront nous en parler mais que le
public a changé dans pendant le match et
qu'il a beaucoup plus accompagné les
mêlé les chocs les plaquages à la fin du
match qu'au début au début ça restait
relativement festif des champs on était
content d'être là mais on naccompagnait
pas les joueurs et à la fin ça s'est
beaucoup senti peut-être parce que
c'était descousus aussi on sait qu'en
rugby les gens adorent ça au c'est très
agréu dans tous les sens quand on
regarde à la télé qu'on est un peu
stressé c'est différent parce que il y a
certaines transmissions qui étaient
compliqué ce qu'on avait pas vu depuis
très longtemps d'ailleurs c'est
peut-être le seul point noir c'est les
transmissions même Antoine Dupont qui
est quand même le meilleur là-dessus av
avait du mal et Thomas Ramos quand ça
sort main gauche alors comme il est
droitier c'est plus facile dans ce
sens-là mais quand ça sort main gauche
c'est compliqué Adad slim sur Youtube
alors ça y est la théorie du complot
comment c'est souvent le cas on avait vu
d'ailleurs en foot récemment
l'entraîneur des Pays-Bas dire que
l'Argentine tout était écrit et que un
ancien entraîneur des Pays-Bas que
l'Argentine a gagné cette coupe du monde
de foot alors tout était écrit Adad un
arbitrage maison tout sera fait pour que
la France soit championne du monde bah
c'est un peu contradictoire avec notre
discussion sur le matur il y AER donc
non non je crois que là-dessus il y a
vraiment rien à dire sur l'arbitrage à
ce momentl il aurait accordé les 7 Pau
sans sans discuter enfin non non 23h31
l'équipe de France remporte donc son
premier match 2713 contre la la
Nouvelle-Zélande allez on essaie de
parler des joueurs un par un selon vous
tiens chacun chacun votre tour qui était
le meilleur joueur des des Carle ah là
là euh moi je mettrais peato movaka
comme ça spontanément parce que il
rentre à un moment du match c'est pas
prévu il remplace marchand qui se blesse
on sait que sur cette première ligne
normalement les remplacements se font
aux alentours de la 50e minute ou et
donc il est programmé pour ça là il
rentre si je me trompe pas c'est
peut-être dès la 10e minute chose comme
ça et il doit faire tout le match et bah
tient il tient tout le match et
surtoutabitude en plus de de faire tout
le match oui ou sur des matchs en tout
cas pas avec des équipe en tout cas
comme ça il avait battu les Black et il
fait quand même une action absolument
incroyable il joue une pénalité
rapidement à la main et et il traverse
quasiment tout le terrain il donne un
coup de pied enfin av traversé le
terrain en première mi-temps aussi sur
une sur une touche je
crois donc voilà spontanément je
diraisaka en plus comme c'est un
toulousin ça rien oui côté Chauvin s'il
avait été rochelé non non ça vous
intéressait pas ti
Jean-M mais disonsilà qui est le
meilleur français de de ce
match bah je suis de je suis moins
toulousain que mon ami Carl mais je
j'approuve movaka a fait un match
formidable mais je voudrais associer
tous les joueurs de première ligne parce
que je trouve que la première ligne
française que ce soit les ceux qui ont
débuté ou ceux qui ont fini on on été
impeccable une mention pour Reda Wardi
qui était assez formidable atonio a a
plié son son pilier son vis-avis à
plusieurs reprises il a il a obtenu des
pénalités et en deuxème mi-temps la
première ligne a été extrêmement
vaillante aussi donc hommage hommage à
ces premières lignes qui sont souvent
qui font souvent un travail obscur mais
qui sont qui ont été extrêmement solid
et puissants et qui ont fait très mal au
black ce soir àonu sur la première
mi-temps la France n'arrive pas vraiment
à jouer par contre c'est lui qui
rapporte les points à l'équipe de France
parce que c'est lui qui pie les de c'est
c'est lui qui plie de mêl et qui offre 6
points sur les pénalités Bordon vous
votre moi j'ai première ligne je suis
d'accord j'aurais pu mettre aussi la
troisème j'ai trouvé Olivon et et aldrit
bon mais je pense que je mettrai Thomas
Ramos parce qu'il a mis les points au
pied quand même que il a été bon dans la
couvertureè il en a raté de non trois la
dernière la dernière c'est jaminé ah
c'est jaminé vous avez raison et il fait
une erreur avec un en avant direct avec
en avant sur une réception mais il est
quand même costaud sur la réception il
Provo que le carton jaune il provoque
une deuxième pénalité sur une sur une TR
sur une troisième réception je l'ai
trouvé assez solide il a pas mal supplé
à l'ouverture où il a où il a su
importer impulser un peu dynamisme
donc ben moi je vouis mettre Olivon mais
allez je vais changer un peu je vais
mettre Wardi je trouvé très très précis
très rigoureux ce qui était pas
forcément sa force avant et on a vu
notamment sur les malles qu'il arrivait
a bloqué les joueurs d'une manière très
maline il mettait les bras les clés de
bras tout en restant dans les règles je
l'ai trouvé très malin il a fait quasi
60 minutes donc pour un finisseur ça
reste très bien il a commencé et et puis
évidemment les arrières un match un peu
compliqué pour les arrières on en
parlera peut-être après vous nous dites
sur YouTube sur Le Figaro.fr qui a été
le meilleur Français ce soir qui a été
le moins bon vous ne m'avez pas cité le
meilleur joueur du monde Antoine Dupont
Vincent match correct sans plus non il a
été cadenassé il fait quand même une
sacrée course face à notre ami Ben
Barret il le force à amener le ballon en
touche qui permet de gagner terrain le
du terrain il récupère une pénalité il a
une pression très forte aux sorties de
mêlé où la balle est souvent éjectée un
peu vite par notre troisème ligne et il
Arve à s'en sortir non non il fait il
fait quand même un bon match
euh avec la pression qu'il avait
d'autres joueurs auraiit explosé et on
aurait pu être plus explosé non je Tai
trouvé je trouvais assez bon il a pas
été un match un comment dit un impact
player déterminant un match winner mais
il a été il a fait quand même une il a
été en difficulté sur quelques
transmissions il m'a sememblé mais je
l'ai trouvé je l'ai trouvé pas trop
mauvais
oui je suis d'accord vous nous demandiez
le meilleur donc non mais un avis sur an
forcément c'est le joueur duquel on va
parler à chaque avantmch à chaque
débriefing obligatoirement les les
Blacks avaient un plan contre lui et on
voit que Aron Smith le chassait mais en
permanence il a sur les sorties de mêl
je suis d'accord c'est vrai qu'elle
sortait pas très bien parfois mais c'est
il avait Aaron Smith sur le dos au même
moment où il prenait la balle donc
c'était compliqué pour lui de de de
s'exprimer correctement aujourd'hui
Jean-Marc Vincent votre avis sur le
match d'Antoine
lupont assez d'accord ce que je viens
d'entendre Aaron Smith a été extrêmement
vigilant il nous avait il nous avaient
déclaré les blagues qu'ils avaient un
plan anti antiupon qu'ils ont mis en
œuvre et ils ont observé un trucon Smith
n'est plus ce qu'il était mais il est
encore un joueur très malin très
intelligent il a une expérience énorme
il a compris que du pont notamment il
aime bien faire un petit pas quand il
sort sa balle de la extrait son ballon
de la mêlée pour pour pour lancer son
attaque il l'attendait à ce moment-là et
il lui a bouclé les bras et donc Antoine
s'est retrouvé vraiment bloqué
quoi effectivement un quand même un
super match d'Antoine Dupont on l' vu
mais on s'habitue
peut-être c'est ça voilà le problème
c'est que voilà c'est Antoine Dupont et
peut-être qu'on s'attend mieux à des
choses forcément fabuleuse mais comme on
le disait au début de match il est ciblé
il est ciblé par l'équipe adverse et
l'équipe adverse met des plans
antiantoine lupont même si c'est
compliqué à mettre en place mais en même
temps même si il fait un match un peu
ened qu'il est très surveillé quand vous
êtes sur le terrain vous voyez que c'est
le patron il y a deux trois cadres mais
lui il est il est auudessus si je dire
audessus de la mêlée vu la position
qu'il a mais c'est vrai il a c'est lui
qui conduit le jeu regardez l'ESS de Pau
les deux renversements d'attaque c'est
lui il comprend très vite il donne un
ballon impeccable à jaliber qui qui met
les jambes et qui qui offre un caviar à
l'élier à penau il est déclencheur quand
même sur une action comme ça c'est le
cerveau de l'équipe il y a pas de doute
euh dans dans les nombreux papiers que
qu'il y a eu sur Antoine Dupont et là je
vais citer le papier de jean-mar Gonin
parce qu'il va pas le faire lui-même
mais dans le Figaro Magazine de la
semaine dernière sur le village d'où il
vient casselen où il raconte comment
Antoine Dupont vient avec ses copains
reste le même d'ailleurs et dans dans
dans tous ces papiers il y a il y a une
citation de d'Antoine Dupont qui dit le
but ce n'est pas de bien jouer c'est de
gagner donc je pense qu'il serait
d'accord avec nous ce soir ah je vous
confirme pas très bien joué ou il a
peut-être pas été le meilleur mais c'est
pas grave parce que l'important c'était
de gagner 27 13 face au black il l'
aurait signé tout de suite je salue
Jérôme de lance qui nous passe un
bonjour Depuis le 62 il vient de
s'abonner à la page Youtube bienvenue
Jérôme il est très content de la
victoire des Bleus on a parlé du des
meilleurs joueurs qui a été le moins bon
qui ont qui sont ceux qui ont peut-être
un peu raté leur match et qui pourraiit
être en danger sur de prochaines grandes
échéances al moi j'en ai un tout de
suite automatique sur t en danger sur
les prochaines échéances c'est mu fana
alors on sait qu'il est pas en enfin il
ne jouera pas puisque dti reprendra sa
place on peut le rappeler c'est le
centre qui a remplacé dentil l'habituel
titulaire ex le meilleur deuxème centre
du monde rien que ça ah oui dentil on
peut y aller il est passé à côté de son
match oui parce que c'est un joueur qui
qui aime avoir des espaces généralement
je suis sûr que contre l'Uruguay ou la
namibi ça aurait donné un super match
mais là il a été il a été quand même
très il a eu du mal à aller dans
l'impact il avait du mal à se pencher
dans les cont puis a pas beaucoup libéré
son ballon puis on se troué en défense
au centre donc mais al attendez vous
m'inquiétez parce que dti il est pas
revenu encore est-ce qu'il va revenir il
devrait revenir d'ici l'italié même les
quarts de finale il y a pas trop
d'inquiétude on l'a dit les deux proch
oui oui même il était pressenti pour ce
match les deux prochains matchs
devraient pas être très compliqués pour
l'équipe de France donc dti sera
préservé voilà il devrait jouer face à
l'Italie et être en forme face au quart
de finale on abordera notre adversaire
je pense tout à l'heure bon vous êtes
d'accord avec Augustin Vincent ouais
j'aais dit j'aurais dit Mo fana aussi
euh grosso modo la paire de cente a été
a été un peu discrète
fikou par fikou j'ai trouvé pas mauvais
moi pas mauvais il a pesé un pe pe on
pas trouvé tout court finalement on l'a
pas beaucoup vu il a fait son travail
défensif comme à chaque fois mais la
faiblesse été Mo mais surtout avec ce
que ce que vous disiez à l'instant sur
sur dy je pense que c'est le joueur qui
a le plus à perdre mais après une équipe
qui gagne face au black ben voilà oui on
a pas envie de la changer parce que
c'est difficile hein Carl votre avis je
vous demande de me trouver un joueur qui
a était un peu en dessous on parit déjà
liber en première mi-temps à la mi-temps
vous oui il s'est rattrapé en deuxième
c'est ce qu'on disait euh c'est à partir
du moment c'est vous vous souvenez on
s'est dit pendant la mi-temps ce qu'il
faut qu'il fasse c'est reprendre
confiance et faire la passe au pied qui
va amener l'essai et ben c'est ce qu'il
a fait c'est un coup de Rin voilà et et
Jalbert c'est pour ça aussi que Fabien
gâtier l'a pris c'est parce que il y a
des fulgurances comme ça et avec penau
bah ça ça fonctionne et avec la tonicité
qu'il a on a même cru qu'il irait tout
seul au bout il a décidé parce VO jou
ralenti on voit qu'il aurait pas pu y
aller bien le coou Jean-Marc je vous
demande d'enlever un joueur dans ce 15
de départ lequel vous a un peu
déçu bon alors je suis d'accord avec
avec mes confrères sur sur fana qui à
mon avis aussi bien en défense qu'en
attaque en attaque il naviguait assez
bêtement je dirais il s'est fait boucler
il glissait au moment où il faisait ses
ses ses prises d'appui enfin c'est
vraiment c'était vraiment pas terrible
mais il y a moi je PRS il y en a un qui
fait un match relativement médiocre
c'est Gabin Villière moi j'ai pas trouvé
son jeu très sûr euh il est parti dans
des crochets assez nuls il s'est fait
boucler une fois il se fait gratter un
ballon hyper dangereux alors qu'on est
dans les 22 c'est là où on prend presque
un essai pas connaiss à cause de lui
seulement à cause de lui parceil aurait
pu dégager en touche sagement et il
tente il tente une contre-attaque avec
trois défenseurs face à lui et décochets
de Top 14 face à la défense des All
Blacks ça le fait pas donc franchement
Gabin Villiard a a a surjoué et il a
tenté des contres qui étaient très
dangereux à mon avis il y a un excellent
louisberry qui attend qui attend
derrière de de prendre sa place c'est
vrai ouais moi je j'aimerais bien avoir
des crochets de Top 14 bon bon on verra
s'il y a du du changement on va se
projeter allez question un peu peut-être
bête peut-être trop rapide est-ce que
c'est l'équipe de France la plus forte
de l'histoire ils ne sont pas champions
du monde ils ont gagné un grand chlem ça
on peut le dire déjà à leur actif mais
vous regardez notre attitude devant la
une victoire comme celle-ci est-ce que
c'est la plus forte équipe de France
qu'on a jamais vu tiens Jean-Marc vous
avez connu beaucoup d'équipes de France
je vous redonne la parole dites-nous
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu ça
ah oui j'ai les cheveux blancs
euh comment dire j'ai connu des équipes
de France extrêmement brillantes le
French FLIR peut-être même qu'il y avait
plus de French FLIR que celle-ci mais
comment compare les époques là on est
dans un professionnalisme total avec une
préparation énorme des joueurs physique
mental technique
tactique je veux dire c'est une cette
équipe de France a un côté arme fatal
que les autres que ses prédécesseurs
n'avaient pas très honnêtement il y a
une espèce de science du jeu de comme
l'ont dit Carl et d'autres il y a cette
espèce même une panique pas ils ont une
espèce de solidité encore une fois il y
a des cadres qui tiennent l'équipe c'est
vraiment de ce point de vue là une
équipe très rare et en plus avantage que
personne pour l'instant n'a signalé
regardez la moyenne d'âge des
différentes équipes éip parmi les
favorites la France est dans une tranche
d'âge autour de 26 ans et plus jeune que
toutes ses rivales et ça aussi ça va
compter d'ici d'ici octobre et cette
équipe de France est en pleine maturité
et ils ont encore de jeunes jambes et
des corps qui sont pas trop meurtris par
rapport à leurs adversaires et et et on
sent que c'est c'est c'est vraiment des
patrons que c'est vraiment des des voilà
ils ont plus aucun complexe et presque
même c'est eux les favoris en fait ils
ont joué ils ont joué ce match comme si
c'était eux les favoris face à la
Nouvelle-Zélande et c'était bah la
Nouvelle-Zélande alors je veux pas faire
un mais c'est comme si on joue comme si
c'était le pays de gale ou comme si
c'était une équipe vraiment inférieure à
nous et que on va prendre on va prendre
la foudre pendant un petit moment mais
après on va se relever et tout ira bien
vient de lancer un sondage sur Youtube
vous nous dites oui vous nous dites non
à cette question est-ce la meilleure
équipe de France de l'histoire j'attends
un peu avant de vous donner les
résultats je salue Alain qui lu nous
salue San Francisco et qui est d'accord
avec vous Jean-Marc villère un peu
absent car la meilleure équipe de France
de l'histoire ou non alors je répondrai
pas directement à la question je jeis
d'accord avec Jean margodin c'est
l'équipe qui est la plus s un crochet du
Top 14 là qu' ma question non mais c'est
l'équipe qui est la plus en confiance et
sûr de son jeu euh à chaque coupe du
monde on avait une équipe de France soit
on se disait elle y arrivera pas soit
elle était réduite à faire un exploit
mais une fois qu'elle avait fait un
exploit en battant une nation du Sud
après elle retombait dans ses
travers elle arrivait pas à faire un
deuxième exploit de suite là on sent une
force une force qui a qui va euh Fabien
Galtier leur a donné cette confiance en
eux qui fait que ils ont pu sur les 4
ans qui qui ont précéderé la Coupe du
Monde battre chacune des équipes qu'ils
vont devoir affronter là et donc savoir
que c'est possible jusqu'ici quand on
affrontait les BLS on se disait non mais
en fait on y arrivera pas c'est les
dieux du rugby ils ont un secret qu'on n
pas voilà nous on peut y AR un
malentendu ça peut marcher vas-y fonce
quoi c'est Jean-Claude dus je vois que
vous connaissez bien oui chacun ses
références c'était un exploit et du coup
on on se souvient d'ailleurs des
exploits on peut les citer il y en a eu
que quelques-uns là on a l'impression en
revanche que la France est devenue une
machine et quelque part dans cette
deuxième mi-temps elle a joué comme
jouent les Blacks avant c'est-à-dire
qu'elle faisait des relances qu'elle
arrivait à récupérer des ballons et et à
marqué des essais sur des ballons de
récupérationinstant votre avis toujours
la même question c'est la l'équipe de
France la plus froide et la plus sûre de
de son jeu la plus forte de l'histoire
si elle est champion du monde si elle
est perd en quart de finale on dira vite
bienite de ça donc il reste encore se
matchs 6 matchs pour pour ça mais on
verra Augustin c'est l'équipe la plus
complètes on a eu des équipes élégantes
Blanco la paliss des supers équipes dans
plutôt dans les années 90 ensuite on a
eu des équipes très physique en 2007 on
avait une super équipe aussi et qui
avait du mal dans les transmissions je
me souviens beaucoup de fautes de main
on on se scpit le chignon en permanence
devant sa télé et là elle est complète
sur tous les domaines et ça c'est c'est
vraiment marquant c'est que il y a pas
une faiblesse qui ressort il y a des
joueurs qui qui qui passe un peu à côté
mais dans l'ensemble il y a pas de
faiblesse collective quand vous regardez
ce match là ou est-ce la le meilleur 15
de France de l'histoire sur Youtube pour
l'instant 84 % d'entre vous pensent que
oui attention à la désillusion potentiel
dans les dans les semaines qui viennent
bon on se projette sur la sur la suite
euh trois matchs maintenant Namibie
Uruguay c'est ça Uruguay Italie bon les
deux urugu Italie Uruguay Italie les
deux prochains matchs une formalité on
va passer ass vite quo que on tourne on
fait tourner l'quip alors c'est ça par
exemple est-ce que je vais revoir
Antoine Dupont titulaire est-ce que je
vais revoir Thomas Ramos titulaire il
faut faut pas négliger la température
les organismes on ont puisé dans
beaucoup de réserves là au ce soir
malgré tout c'est les Blacks on a vu des
contacts je vous sentais frémir par
certains moments quand même si on
entendait pas mais c'était violent il
faut que les corps se se ressource donc
il faut faire tourner évidemment mettre
l'équipe B oui mais alors tourner
jusqu'à quand est-ce que laisser trop
longtemps les joueurs au frigo c'est pas
dangereux faut qu'il joue aussi là ça du
jeudi prochain face à urug je pense qu'
fara tourner et après c'estàd combien de
changement combien de joueurs seront
titulaires combien de titulaires de ce
match seront je pense moins de la moitié
moi je pense qu'il y 5 joueurs qui
seront titulaires qu'Antoine Dupont sera
pas sera même pas sur le banc par contre
face à la Roumanie on va avoir une
équipe mixte et on va remettre la grosse
pas jouer contre rie mais peut-être face
à la Nami équipe mixte et euh et contre
l'Italie l'équipe type qu'on a vu ce so
à nouveau contreitalie alors qu'on se
rapprochera du quart de finale mais
justement il faut recréer reprendre le
rythme pour reprendre rythme ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'Antoine Dupont à mon avis
jouera soit la Namibie soit l'Uruguay
dans sa totalité ou quasiment parce
qu'il aura cœur de se rattraper aussi de
certaines choses il a là il veut montrer
que c'est le meilleur joueur du monde et
puis il y a d'autres enjeux aussi il y a
les enjeux de meilleurs marqueur du
tournoi il y a enux de rattraper des les
essais pour penau des petits enjeux sur
lesquels ils peuvent s'amuser vous avez
raison Damien Pau qui est devenu ce soir
le 4è meilleur marqueur des
vous dépassé Vincent clair ça doit être
non Vincent CLA est encore devant on
voit on voit ensemble Serge Blanco 38
Vincent 34 il rrapé saintendré 32 et
donc ils sont deux à être avoir atteint
la barre des 30 Jean-Marc vous est-ce
que vous changez vous changez tout pour
le prochain match ou non vous vous
adaptez progressivement et comment vous
faites en gros pour arriver pleinbour en
quart de
finale
[Musique]
B écoutez il y a là ça a été franchement
un match extrêmement dur physiquement
c'est bon d'abord ce sont les blques en
plus je me répète mais les conditions
climatiques sont épuisantes le rugby
comme vous savez c'est un sport à les
cadences répétées c'est très dur et je
pense qu'il faut faire reposer je pense
que Galtier fera reposer le plus de
cadres possible alors après il fera son
choix peut-être qu'il y a des joueurs
qui veulent se racheter Antoine Dupon
peut-être parce qu'il était un peu en
dessous il y en a quelques-uns qui qui
va replonger dans le truc pour qu'il
trouve un meilleur rythme
voilà pourquoi pas puis il y a Arthur
Vincent enfin il y a des gens qui on qui
ont leur place mais franchement là avec
lespreuve qui viennent de subir je
rigole pas parce que vraiment il faisait
très très chaud franchement pour jouer
rugby il fallait fallait là ils ont ils
ont perdu des ls ces garçons ils vont
vraiment avoir besoin de repos donc
remettre les crampons Judi à lî face à
face à l'Uruguay il y en a peut-être
qu'il préféreront regarder ça depuis les
tribunes j'ai l'impression JeanMarc que
vous aussi vous avez souffert vous avez
du crier chanter et perdre perdre
quelques litres d'eau en tribune je me
trompe non j'ai passé j'ai passé l'âge
vous vous trompez mais mais j'ai eu
chaud j'ai participé j'ai poussé en mêlé
mais moins dur
que j'ai pas ma place en première ligne
même même pas il était en for il était
en forme j'ai passé le B à côté de lui
il était très en forme quand même je
m'en doute je m'en doute bon première
place du groupe pas assuré mais on peut
dire qu'on a un pied et quatre orteils
sur cette première place maintenant
qu'est-ce qui nous attend en quart de
finale ça c'est très important l'Irlande
l'Afrique du Sud est-ce que c'est une
bonne chose de finir en tête de ce
groupe Carl oui oui oui parce que vous
marquez les esprits on l'a dit tout à
l'heure il faut marquer les esprits dans
une coupe du monde là on a envoyé un
signal on va terminer devrait terminer
premier quel que soit l'adversaire en
quart de finale on sait que c'est une
autre montagne voilà l'Irlande ils sont
premier
classement World rugby l'Afrique du Sud
a marqué les esprits en en laminant les
blacks dans un match de préparation on
sait que ce sont deux montagnes qu'il va
falloir affronter de toute façon pour
être champion du monde il faut battre
les plus grandes nations donc n'a pas le
choix donc ça sert à rien de dire je
préfère X ou Y on affrontera celui qui
se présentera à nous et croyez-moi je
pense que Fabien Galt a déjà préparé
Gustin ouais moi je pose plus une
question de
calendrier là on n pas vu le match
Irlande Afrique du Sud ça se trouve
l'Irlande va passer complètement à côté
de sa coupe du monde l'Afrique du Sud
aussi et là on aurait peut-être préféré
savoir qui allait finir prier ou deuxiè
du groupe oui mais bon évidemment avec
ce raisonnement là vous êtes pas
champion du monde oui le match aura lieu
le 23 septembre voilà je suis d'accord
pour champion du monde faut battre tout
le monde mais il y a des équipes comme
l'Afrique du Sud qu'il faut mieux battre
en finale parce que pour être champion
du monde en battant l'Afrique du Sud en
car il faut ensuite gagner la demi
ensuite gagner la finale et c'est une
équipe extrêmement usante physiquement
et je pense que autant sur le match et
tout aussi difficile de battre les
Irlandais que les Sud-Africains mais
qu'on se remet peut-être moins
difficilement parce qu'on a l'habitude
dans le casre du tournoi de jouer les
Irlandais et de repartir au combat la
semaine prochaine que la semaine d'après
que que les springbx qui sont quand même
extrêmement difficiles qui ont innové en
créant une équipe avec six remplaçants
avec six remplaçants devant sur un banc
qui en compte 7 qui peuvent nous faire
très mal et
avec des organismes qui auront souffert
il faudra ensuite se remobiliser pour
gagner la dem demi-finale face une
équipe qui sera sur une bonne dynamique
qui sera soit l'Argentine soit
l'Australie soit l'Angleterre et puis
après gagner en finale ça va être
quelque chose extrêmement dur et
d'ailleurs on a une jurisprudence juste
très rapidement c'est 2007 quand on bat
les blacks et qu'après on est
complètement cuit et mentalement et
physiquement dans l'histoire des coupes
du monde il y a qu'une seule équipe qui
a battu l'Afrique du Sud et qui a fini
championne championne du monde en phase
de en phase éliminatoire c'est
l'Australie en 99 en face la France
avait battu la Nouvelle-Zélande dans un
match dantesque et était pas redescendu
de ce match Jean-Marc vous préférez voir
qui en quart de finale lard ou l'Afrique
du Sud ne me dites pas que vous attendez
le match du 23
septembre non moi c'est ces deux équipes
qui se valent on connaî mieux les
Irlandais parce qu'on les joue t tous
les ans ils nous ont battu au nous ont
battu dernières naation c'est une
excellente équipe il y a pas besoin de
faire un dessin bon je reviens à mon
argument de l'âge les Irlandais sont
âgés donc au faire à mure de la
compétition vont peut-être suuser ils
vont se blesser on a oublié de dire
pendant la notre causerie là queon a
déjà on a perdu un talonur ce soir je
sais pas s'il va revenir et toutes les
équipes vont perdre des joueurs des
joueurs cadres marchand c'est quand même
pas n'importe qui et
donc à la hauteur des quarts de finale
moi je pense qu'on connaît mieux
l'Irlande donc je préférerais prendre
l'Irlande mais mais malgré tout ça c'est
ça sera un match à très haut niveau et
c'est pas gagné c'est clair et et on
peut aussi préférer l'cosse finalement
parce que pourquoi pourquoi pas l'cosse
si s'il y a un pe
fait termin prier nous faire tomber
contreécse le pronostic de notre ami
David qui pense que l'Écosse Batt
l'Irlande on y croit ça c'est
intéressant possible il il peuvent
passer les poules après premier du
groupe ça me paraî très mais justement
il faut qu'il
deè bon merci messieur on vous rel il y
a du monde autour de vous quelle est
l'ambiance là dehors les gens restent
s'en vont fait la fête on a vu danser un
peu derrière
vous
alors un peu il y a eu des gens alors on
n'est pas forcément dans les tribunes où
ça le plus chanter parce qu'on est côté
média pour descendre plus vite voilà
pour les informations on est côté média
côté tribune on va dire VIP donc c'est
pas forcément là où les gens sortent le
plus on va dire peut-être que de l'autre
côté du stade c'est plus la fête mais en
tout cas à la fin du à la fin du match
il y a quand même des gens qui était là
qui qui qui qui chantaiit qui dansait ça
ça a quand même duré un petit moment
mais là tout le M monde rentre mais d'un
côté le match est terminé depuis bientôt
45 minutes non ça se disperse c'est
normal mais il fait bon alors évidemment
les gens flan c'est pas comme pendant le
tournoi destination où sur il y a du
vent de la pluie et on est press de
rentrer même s'il est 14h ou 17h
exactement merci beaucoup messieurs on
vous relâche merci jean-mart Gonin
d'être venu devant le stade avec Vincent
pour livrer votre votre analyse messieur
merci beaucoup on fait un qu'est-ce que
vous attendez là du prochain match on
peut faire déjà un petit pronostic on en
met combien combien de point d'avance
face à l'Uruguay oh là là 30 40 c'est
possible plus oui oui plus oh bah oui
enfin l'Uruguay c'est quand même pas un
niveau euh à partir de en dessous de
combien de points on a raté notre match
20 25 40 points je pense qu'on a ah oui
il faut en mettre plus de 40 bon nous
verrons cela merci beaucoup merci de
nous avoir suivi je remercie tous ceux
qui ont préparé cette cette émission et
puis je montre quand même la la Une du
Figaro de de demain on la voit ensemble
euh alors l'inflation oui et
malheureusement j'arrive pas à voir du
monde de rugby face All Black des bleus
conquérrents et j'ai plus après et G et
il n pas merci Augustin de m'avoir aidé
l'écran est trop loin pour nos petits
yeux ah ça y est peut-être que vous
voyez mieux dites-moi Augustin alors f
black desbleleux conquérant et gagnant
2713 pour l'ouverture de la compétition
merci beaucoup 2713 oui on a le score je
vous remercie d'ailleurs parce que c'est
vous qui nous avez aidé à faire venir
toutes ces personnes en plateau je
remercie Sacha budu je remercie riad
beckir et puis tous ceux qui sont venus
ici dans ces canapés on fera ça encore
au moins les match ble quatre matchs
maintenant puisqueon peut le dire on est
qualifié voilà allez Virginie le
trionire également qui vous a aidé
Augustin à à inviter tous ce monde en
plateau et à préparer cette soirée on se
dit à bientôt on se dit évidemment à
lundi pour les autres actualités puis à
jeudi pour le prochain match
salut